welcome to this video playing Mara
anguish not no way i pronouncing that
correctly yep so well let's see yeah
maybe okay go with the story five this
is czech republic oh yeah so what came
the v ni game okay normal development i
guess i don't really have any good
experiences on a good experience any
experience with d5 against the setup
maybe I should write a six first I never
liked it if they get my my prepare that
that easily okay come on to take it it
simply isn't taking that thing okay um I
can one let's go Tess 25 yeah I really
don't know what what to do if I'm just
sitting then allow SF what stuff coming
it shouldn't be that bad actually if he
takes Knight X there is not that's not
any particular pressure on e5 so should
be should be quite ok this position
he's got the bishop habit quite often in
this kind of structure you get it traded
why a bishop e6 bishop d5 quite
difficult to avoid that trade for what
now yeah I think it was a good decision
to let up lady five okay so he wants to
simplify with this Bishop Pam hmm
interesting decision I wonder would
wonder if i can go bishop like a bishop
at five for tonight to before no
probably not okay let's let's let's
let's keep it simple and and play it
like that i looked in one is actually
interesting and better came
Jim the bishop pair is something for him
but in a totally symmetric of position
it's difficult to make anything out of
it something something real that same
I queen f 6m Queen f6 might be a good
idea to activate also that of course be
6b five would actually make my night how
more stable on that d 5 square the night
is a good piece of course I don't know
maybe maybe you play C for anyway no it
doesn't so let's do that wow I can just
take that now right which with nothing
going on let's do that okay I play that
you might play Quincy seven not a good
idea probably so let's do this
oh yeah okay it's got a queen d for
coming it ok I've got Luke a for him in
this position look a four-step some way
some way to do something about the
somewhat unstable position of the rope
here look a nice got Queen d2 actually
that's quite quite convincing so let's
go here
my idea is Queen to e7 and then possibly
Bishop t5 cutting off the rook I'm
expecting Quincy for Queen d2 something
like that yeah all that move but now
I've could look the area for trades
I have to have to be modest and it's not
really not much I can do Queen d2
something quindi to check their can
check me take be 7i takes it to take
after maybe maybe check so I played that
very quickly something here is got no
actually not okay
Oh Bishop takes Queen fu check so that's
not on
it's all not very exciting and he still
has this has a little bit of an edge
probably Quincy five yeah Quincy five
it's a bit bit annoying that move Bishop
c4 this a for shrimp c6 okay hmm Jim
you should see six Bishop c4 I go here
to have a four color so I possibly a for
I can take with the Queen I Emily
doesn't want to do anything here okay
okay that is slightly more comfortable
for him I but by the way maybe I'm quick
with my king no we just has everything
covered no and doesn't really matter it
just equal gras our third game plan just
draw yeah that was quite a boring game
but sometimes it's difficult yeah you
just have to be have to play what what's
necessary and here there wasn't much
that I can do after deform what else
Bishop f5 maybe but I wasn't sure if you
just do does this move for example if
this gave me anything yeah so I think it
was probably okay him I oh it's a nice
one and I'd be Who I am teck teck teck
teck teck teck interesting yeah that's
nice move Queen d2 Bishop f5 interesting
definitely okay for black jump okay what
I went for the sound the sound wave
anything Quincy aids or queen d 7 I ok
for you know I saw that too late they
have this rook a4a GM this is
interesting this kind of move yeah if he
does that have root a form huh there
would have been interesting okay I'm I
was okay with this
and check that simple approach here we
just have a complete complete draw yeah
that was a bit boring but what can you
do as I said sometimes you have to play
what you have to play and then it's the
draw okay well thanks for watching